last question today hey David people in
the United States are getting more and
more non-religious fewer and fewer
identify with any major religion I'm
wondering as people let go of religious
identity is politics becoming the new
religion ah so how are we identifying a
religion I guess we're talking about a
sort of dogmatic reinforced set of
beliefs
yeah working backwards from your
conclusion right like you're part of a
team yeah like your beliefs are already
set in stone and you try to find
evidence that supports your theory I
don't know that everybody would agree
with that I think a lot of people would
say no no I came to my conclusions
because they're the right conclusions
not I've sought out evidence to support
them because I've already determined my
conclusions but yet I think there is an
element to that I think that for some
people politics has already been a
religion and I don't know that that's
necessarily changing I think we just
have less religion and you don't always
have to rep replace religion with
something equivalent as we've learned
more about the natural world and our
scientific knowledge has improved people
have started to walk away from religion
and you're seeing that in a number of
different countries does that mean that
science becomes a religion no I
completely reject that idea and in fact
science has an internal self-correcting
error error correcting mechanism that is
fundamentally different than religion so
I reject totally the idea that science
is a religion now can anybody fall into
circular unfalsifiable or at least
unwilling to have falsified dogmatic
type beliefs about anything
absolutely but big picture I don't think
politics is really replacing religion I
don't think science is replacing
religion I think that science and our
knowledge of the world is making
religion increasingly obsolete and
people don't find the need for it
altogether right it's more that dogmatic
thinking that we have to move beyond
from and when we talk about science we
talk about politics we have to make sure
that we're having those conversations in
good faith right and that we're willing
to take in new evidence and change our
minds otherwise it does become
like religion in a sense the good thing
is an interesting one because a lot of
religious debate is not happening in
good faith in the sense that people
aren't really debating in a way that
they're open to having their minds
changed when you do science or politics
the right way part of challenging your
beliefs is really really a an inherent
part of it some people don't do that
there are people whose religious beliefs
or scientific beliefs fall under that
umbrella that is that is like religion
but for the most part it shouldn't be
that way and he can't always just be
trying to win right you actually have to
seek out the truth hopefully hopefully
unfortunately the way it's practiced by
many is not actually that way but no
religion is not being replaced by
politics and religion is not being
replaced by science our entire world is
changing as we get more of an
understanding of it okay we have a
fantastic bonus show for you today we
will also be next week is just a normal
week right this week had in studio out
of studio guest host all sorts of stuff
yeah but next week it's gonna be just a
normal old-fashioned week of David
Pakman show episodes I think I'll make
it in all five days what about you
oh boy we'll talk about that after join
us on the bonus show WWE Champion com
slash David Pakman show